what's the deal with airplane peanuts
we are deep into this episode and we've
not had a female comedian up tonight so
what I did I went through the bucket and
it took me a while this is a heavily
very very real sausage stew in this
bucket tonight but I was able to find a
female comedian hopefully this is a
female comedian we're gonna we're gonna
fingers crossed here Make some noise for
Ellie in space everybody here you go
Ellie in space
balancing the scales of equality all
right
[Music]
[Applause]
set
oh you son of a [__] I tell these guys
there's one [__] rule [__] you
can't help yourself remember when an
arcade game was uh the the peak ah oh
what do you talk do you not see that I
didn't even see it that's my dude that
is my claim to fame I cannot believe I
actually own an arcade machine five
grand to fix it yeah at our age level
the movie big was the yeah the Pinnacle
of of luxury that trampoline indoors was
there anything better than that bunk bed
skateboarding on the hardwood he's
[__] a weird lady Coke machine yeah
it was all right that was my name in
college
I had plenty of really great nights
doing stand-up but I had jokes like I
would go up there and say like I wish I
were Mexican and a realtor
sure so that I could start a business
called what up homes
and like that would get a massive
realtor so I could ask
[Music]
why did you do that just uh
is there something just to make sure
that we could oh the levels for the
audio well yeah it was some certain
things like because I didn't hear it
that well I want to make sure we could
mix that properly okay cool
[Laughter]
I was thinking about I would love if I
was Mexican and a realtor so I could
have a business called what up homes
[Applause]
[Music]
Cleveland's finest right there you're
good Cleveland's finest you're real good
see that you could they could they can't
do that in Cincinnati hey careful I
refer to myself as a he
they can't do that in Cincinnati
you know
[Applause]
you talk about the things
before the coffee grinds
brother
I forgot to tell you I'm doing like uh
wrestling I'm working on wrestling guys
I like wrestling guys yeah you listen to
me and you listen good brother if you
don't put your headphones back on that's
then
do your wrestling guy let's hear yours
yeah
I'll tell you right now me and me and
Saleem
together
all day man as you want to hear yours
Bobby's wasn't good Andrew go ahead
I thought it was actually really good it
was funny but like it's like look at the
clown that wasn't like he wasn't gonna
play a wrestling
all of your impressions sound like
you're turning into a frog
I guess what do you do in play Society
you have to euphemize it like I'm gonna
go release I need to make room I need to
release my bladder
[Laughter]
there's a polite way to be like excuse
me ladies and gentlemen I have to visit
The Powder Room yeah true I have to
release the powder my nose
that's a euphemism for I'm gonna go crap
out drop a mud pile back there dude so
Hamilton mom died I take my shirt off
and drop a horse pile
or you completely asked me like uh
where's the bathroom they go it's over
there I'm like I was thinking more of an
upstairs I was thinking more of a taking
a [__]
maybe I'd have conclusion maybe I need
to get Higher Ground I'm gonna be a loud
crap cause I'm gonna drop a large a
gigantic a gigantic [__] dump and
it's gonna need to travel downwards we
need gravity behind this log it's a log
plume I'm gonna need to get up to the
top should be like did you ever clog
your toilet how big was the turd because
mine's about to be probably record size
right now what's the biggest
what's the biggest turd your toilets
ever choked down because I'm about to
choke your turret
how big is the hole in your toilet
because
yeah you'll never guess who clogs the
turret between people women can clog the
turtle too yeah dude I mean I don't
think it's the pile though I think they
over what you think they over wipe I
don't think women drop piles like that
dude I'm definitely I'll never stop
talking about my aunt's turd Mike
it was just a regular you know like when
you were a kid you had no agenda on the
day at all yeah just walk in my cousin's
house I'm like yeah maybe there you have
like good cereal open up the thing my
cousin's like dude come here you gotta
see my mom
and it's brought me upstairs so it was a
pale Brown that was the first pale the
color of this couch it was a white whale
you've been looking for it ever since
you Captain AF
you gotta find another one
it's the color of this very couch dude
this might be it it might be
it was like a red clay in half like the
Titanic
I think it was Shipwrecked yeah but dude
I mean it was like curled nicely it had
a nice like pine cone cluster to it
nothing oh my God nothing crazy not like
a corn cob but like but it was ribbed on
the way out she felt it
she felt that thing hahaha it was run
like a tree it was like tree rings dude
it was it's yellow it was an old growth
dude it was just three hours old
I told my cousin to cut it in half
get the age of it I think right here was
World War II oh stop showing somebody
your mom stirred it's so [__] funny
dude you gotta see my mom's [__]
he put eyes on it then he preserved it
dude he was like a historical committee
it you cannot flush this turn he was in
there
are you a big you also a jerk you do
journaling too yeah a lot of the kids
you grew up with what do you think their
reaction would be if you told them that
you're journaling I don't want to say
because you have to edit that out just
make more work for Jesse
yeah I got a lot of practice
you know what I like I like to think
about those old pictures of you dog with
[__] with hair and tempos on and they
just think about this kid one day's
gonna be channeling
yeah I Journal a lot yo Doug you may be
one of the only kids on the planet who
punched a drug deal in the stomach and
journaled later
God that is such a water almost came on
my nose
[Music]
I hooked off
against the car I said sure
I had thought thoughts of dog tags just
two days ago because I what I realized
is doing it this way number one it's a
little big it am I wearing a license
plate number two the one that I got for
Jasmine with the kids birthstones
because it goes down this way same thing
but silver same thing does it look like
a stoplight surprise there yeah so on
hers it has three stones with the kit
the kids birthstones to match the TD and
the V oh so you have a t d and a v on
hers yes but with birthstones yes with
their children's birthstone how did you
decide on Silver versus gold at all
she's more silver
um you know it's surprised you surprised
her surprise which isn't nice which is
the way to go did you came home with
something wrapped yes they wrapped it up
for me and this was a just because gift
just because and when did you give it to
her I gave it to her about a week ago
take me through that moment you came
home I came home are you excited I came
home I was excited I had a little bag I
had a little bag it was late though I
got I got I picked up the gift at about
4 4 P.M I didn't get home till about 10
30 11 so if the kids were asleep
everybody was asleep okay Jasmine wants
to sleep but I thought she was she was
she thought this was grounds for a wake
up yes so I didn't necessarily wake her
up with my hands or any physical
activity I got a a toothbrush like a
motorized toothbrush that I brought
started brushing my teeth in the bedroom
not in the bathrooms
[Laughter]
that's fine with that okay
so she started listening is it motorized
or sonic electric electric
motorized wheelchair but a toothbrush
all right so she woke up yeah she woke
up and then she woke up and she was like
woke up she goes why are you brushing
your teeth in the bedroom and I was like
oh I didn't mean to wake you up sorry
and she goes yes you did you were
brushing your teeth in the bedroom and I
was like yeah I'm sorry I was like while
you're up though I said and then I
pulled this out and I swear to God her
first thing she was like are those the
kids initials I was like yeah she goes
it looks like a license plate
[Laughter]
yeah so I said I said I don't think it
does it's a dog tag and then she goes
why would you get a dark Tech with the
kids initials I swear to God and then I
was like that's terrible and I was like
I was like oh I was like well here's
yours and then she was like yeah I'm
gonna open this now and I was like yeah
just open it quick and she's like okay
so she opens it and she goes she looked
at and she goes oh this is the same as
yours except mine has the birthstones
and I was like yeah I was like do you do
you like it like be honest I was like I
could take it back and she was like how
could you take it back
oh my God she goes
exactly
she goes how can you take it back it's
customized
and I go I swear to God I go I go I
guess you're right I can't I can't
[Music]
golf Hot Yoga golf Hot Yoga something
like I'm sweating out these demons I'm
getting the sunshine yeah I'm having fun
every night I mean this Mothership thing
you know yes I don't have kids or
anything and I live downtown in a
high-rise so it's like uh I just have
fun yeah all the time sure your life is
perfect phones are locked up so I can
literally say anything I want so yeah
that's what I'm in it for you know I'm
not in it for you know being a
mainstream star or anything like I just
like I like you know go for it saying
[__] yeah like the other night I did a
joke a long story short I did a joke
about it uh I had a gun in my mouth
right and some the crowd laughs at the
end of the joke I don't want to give it
away and then it is the laughter is
going down some Lady In The Crowd Goes
oh now I'm like what's your problem lady
and she goes I don't like jokes about
guns and mouths my dad killed himself
that way I go lady I've known you for
eight seconds and I know exactly why you
did it
yes he is a little bit better now about
um social interactions I will say that
so is there is there a medication you
take to to for you to stay places yeah
yeah oh wow yeah yeah it's working for
his ADHD yeah because well now when I
take the medication I'm actually
listening to what you're saying are you
on it now yeah yeah oh okay why well no
because how does it feel like it no I I
I I don't see that much of a difference
I know what's the dose I know but but no
no but the thing is is that normally
yeah I wouldn't be hearing what you're
saying got it right and now everything
that you're saying 80 of it is like I I
it gets in here and he replies to text
messages now yeah you never used to I
never used to yeah you know he used to
be really bad with that it's terrible
and uh so when I'm talking or when
somebody is talking yeah what do you
what are you doing well I'm probably
thinking about a video game I'm playing
that day so right now I would be
probably thinking about Elden ring well
someone's talking yeah because I don't
there's a boss on there that I've for
two months I'm not kidding you I've been
playing it's the hardest game ever
[__] made by the way and there's a
[__] boss on there where every time I
go I go today's the day and I leveled up
on my [__] magic and I'm just gonna
run faster and magic and hide behind
this pillar or whatever kills me so
that's what I would be thinking about
okay but when you're playing that game
are you thinking about I'm thinking
about you
and there's two things about New York I
just I just don't fit in in the city but
I'm gonna tell you number one I bought
socks earlier today and then look look
these are the kind of socks oh you got
the toe dip yeah like I'm a casual ninja
[Laughter]
please that's how [__] up your city is
that's weird I've never seen that yeah
well why would you buy socks off a guy
on the sidewalk I went to a fancy store
this is fifty dollars what yeah and I
didn't even look at the toe thing I just
bought it and I was like and I put it on
and this is what the [__] happened oh
that's crazy yeah what store is this
well it was like some Japanese store oh
that's a new stock thank you
I like that I love you and the second
thing is is that when I walk down the
street you know because um I have a
viral thing that about me being
molestified guy with Down Syndrome oh
yeah but normally people go um like if
I'm anywhere else they go yeah oh you do
that [__] pocket you talk about the
Down Syndrome but here in New York they
go down syndrome and they just point at
me and other people look at me like I
have down syndromes and I have to do
this weird
it's [__] weird so I don't have Down
syndrome people in New York okay uh uh
okay okay well you know the Korean with
the down again
[Music]
it's hard I can blend together yeah
anyway nice little Asian fusion we call
it yeah there you go I mean Shane Gillis
is Downey exactly right so whites can do
it too I didn't realize that we haven't
done a pod since uh yeah Lena got
twisted bro it's a guy's wife you can't
just say some guy's wife got her I think
you can if he did it if he orchestrated
it so what do we think what do we think
how much do we think they make I think
that's really what it comes down to
that's what we need to know that's what
the internet needs to know what I think
I think they charged too little I
thought it was five bucks or something
yeah I saw the website it's 75 off I was
like you can't get your wife [__] and
then give a discount this is my wife
we're raising the rates it's Black
Friday
[Laughter]
is it Black Friday
it's already hilarious but I thought it
was as well and I was like Jesus the
best movies come out on Thanksgiving bro
it's Black Friday after Thanksgiving oh
is it you've never dealt with a chafed
thigh before Mark oh I was a fat kid
right and you remember I skateboarded in
the Louisiana heat so this was a swampy
Katrina Luhan wet Market down here it
was bad did you have any uh did you have
any like remedies for it how did you fix
it I found well I got a I was uh I
hooked up with a soccer player in
college what was his name
Messi
anyway so this girl's [__] is [__]
you gave great header I'm sorry
um so I'm [__] this girl and she was
a really hot lady but she was a soccer
player and she was like kind of a hippie
and so there wasn't a ton of uh washing
interesting going on she gave me a yeast
infection well this knows all about it
okay we call it jacket
both of you are out of your minds you
both had yeast infection yeast I didn't
know this is pre-internet so I'd have to
I asked the doctor I knew and free
internet you didn't go to college in
[__] 1982. that's true 2003 what is
this 2000
you know that whole thing yeah and uh so
you weren't really just WebMD at all
yeah sure sure so I asked the doctor he
said oh you got to put uh cultures on it
you need to kill the yeast so I went out
and bought yogurt no you dip your nuts
and yogurt nuts in a big Costco
didn't work at all
I tried what if that's uh you went to
the Bayou doctor oh you gonna take your
nuts out put on me some yo play boy you
gotta get Googled yeah squirt some gold
on your nuts for fruit on the bottom
balls on top
but yeah I was
[Music]
and literally you sprayed on and it
bubbles it's searing it off like a rich
person
and that worked wow interesting but it
is bad down there you know I know it's
pretty bad connect isn't that for feet
it's a fungus wow so it worked because
it's all fungi athlete's foot yeah
[__] athletes this this you you
[__] hippie soccer player who's got a
[__] so musty yeah it gives your dick
athlete's foot
exactly
that's [__] wild dude if somebody has
a long distance wedding and I don't want
to go to that I I
that's also okay hold on a second hold
this thought put a pin in this thought I
want to start the battle because this
speaks so much to adulthood and we're
talking about childhood ready here we go
ready start two
b-a-t-t-l-e boys first guest to know the
chant and do it with us listen if I'm
going to law school am I going to watch
suits first probably
[Laughter]
you know who said like Mike Ross and I
gotta tell you if I go to buy a suit I
might go to law school I heard to the
Grapevine that Bill Maher is not a fan
of your impression of him I did an
impression a couple of videos of him he
was just it was the most innocuous
non-offensive non-attagging him videos
they were very he was just like reading
the children was the whole thing yeah oh
would you eat green eggs you wouldn't
you know like he's reading the
children's books it's just a silly it
wasn't even about him really and then he
went on Joe Rogan and he just brought me
up out of nowhere he brought me out
because it was the day you had some guy
was doing a terrible impression of me
said that
that I was in a terrible impression
of him and then Joe was like I oh Kyle
no it's a great impression he's like
Jamie play a video and he goes if you
play that I'm leaving he got really mad
that's so [__] funny and it was and
then after he did that then I felt free
to really do some Bill Martin yeah yeah
and then they got really
um I think I went too far actually why
do you say that well the next video I
did like it was like a billmar gang bang
is what I did next you think he's never
been in a gangbang before
no I I think it's gonna hit home really
hard it was it was a Mako a Make-a-Wish
like it was like make a sketch or like a
sick boy wrote this sketch this is the
premise of it so I'm just like I don't
want to do this but Caleb you know wrote
this
and I would just keep cutting back and
forth this gang bang everyone just
[__] killed my ass anyway
now he probably I actually went to
um Hawaii with him in his plane he
doesn't remember me I'm sure you went to
Hawaii and his private you went on
vacation together this is about like 10
years ago how did this come about I was
dating a girl who was friends with him
we missed our plane to Hawaii so he was
like come on my plane how did you even
get connected with him to come on his
plane my girlfriend at the time was
friends with him oh it must have been
good enough friends to be come to my
plane to watch yes yes that's insane yes
so anyway had they ever dated no no they
were never that seems like that could
have been I'm trying to find the the
pinhole of why he still has a little bit
of a gripe with you I just was like I
don't think he even remembers like I
just I was invisible to him on this trip
like he my his Bat I would always get
his back how many people were on the jet
it was Alan Thicke love a good thick he
was great I loved him and his wife
and then I think two writers and ten
years ago you missed a fly her she says
I'll call Bill and Bill goes come on my
job yeah yeah and you went and his PR
and he doesn't own a jet though he just
had he just he rented yeah chartered one
and he had to show in Hawaii and you
know we had dinners and he it's just so
mean to me I I really clocked him that
trip like I don't like this this guy's
like not nice to me and my girlfriend
was like he's not being an ice cube like
yeah that's what I thought and he just
was not nice to me and and I'm like this
you know they're all billionaires I'm
this like poor guy who you could just be
nice to and like Alan everyone else is
really nice to me yeah I remember going
to dinner was like my hand was shaking
giving my credit card to these dinners
we were going to because you were
nervous yeah I didn't eat like I didn't
order a entree once this act like
because I was
scared at this time I had very little
money and I don't know I was just like
this guy's kind of a dick and then there
was another thing where we were I was at
the ice house and he was on the show and
he he wouldn't let anybody in the green
room I think there's like there's
nowhere to stand yeah the ice house
there was you were in that hallway is
where you'd have to stand and so I'm on
this show and I'm like this [__] guy and
I went in there I sat in there and they
didn't kick me out but it was just like
and he didn't he didn't converse with
you at all no no that I was being I was
betraying a thing this was before the
trip to Hawaii but I just was like this
[__] guy anyway I agree with like
everything he says
I like that and I like sharing but it
would be nice to get the shirts back how
many shirts we up to what
four she left my Minor Threat shirt at
uh access place and that was one of my
favorites and he threw it away why do
you throw it away because it was yours
an accident he said it was an accident
I mean I wasn't before but I'm Gonna
Knock no you're not do not do that do
not do that I'll quit the podcast if you
do that do you see this person often
like at shows then
whoa to him put it down that's what I
will do let's role play I draw the line
draw the line
yeah I know right it's really scary yeah
no and do not give it back but yes you
can see it I got I'll [__] it's not that
bad
oh
that woke you up yeah it's like a little
jolt of coffee
wow is this how many volts not that many
it's really low I look really yeah yeah
yeah it just feels like
it's bark is bigger than its bite yeah
it's a good bark that's why it's a good
weapon yeah yeah it'll scare you before
it stings you you use this on uh don't
give them you keep that over there yeah
I'm not interested you can turn it off
if you want to see if it's bad or not
taze Ethan Ethan good have you done this
get a little hiney over here I haven't
been tased yet even if you hold it down
on yourself it's fine yeah but you your
body doesn't let you it pulls it away
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's not bad I would
let Tom tase me
really yeah you want to get to tastes by
Tom Segura is that what you're saying
yeah would you tase them you tase them I
mean if you're come on you want that to
happen I'll do it for sure wow
all right there you go thanks Ethan this
is great sure about this I mean he's a
little too sure uh where should we do it
oh my God
this is
I've never seen him move like this
before
we know like I'm not it's not on we do
something like like this okay hey hold
it there
you ready yeah you sure
oh
it's not as bad as you think yeah
it's like one of those like gum
shockings yeah yeah just times a hundred
he goes into cardiac arrest okay times a
hundred are you a little power hungry
now a little bit right it feels good
yeah I want more volunteers yeah yeah
yeah she uses all right I'll get that
back that you know it's like one of your
shirts I'm keeping this oh come on
so you were an army brat I was so the
last three times I talked to him he kept
he brought up this thing over and over
and over and then we went into it it was
a fascinating thing that you don't you
well he goes he goes um you guys so what
kind of trauma I go I didn't have trauma
I had a good family and I'd moved around
a lot yeah and then we're doing this
thing and I go well you know I remember
um when I was in the war
um and uh we were stuck in the war in
Lebanon for six months and I used to
always hide when we'd go by the jeep
with the anti-aircraft guns because I
thought they were going to arrest me and
he goes right hey dude you were in a war
okay listen when I'm opening up you
can't open up like that you understand
what do you mean I'm listening to your
story I was opening my heart
metaphorically and then you open your
your shirt literally well autonomy it's
a professional studio it's called
upstaging My Story which is super rude
on your own podcast
seems like you're trying to control me
like a CIA Army brat I'm not a stats do
you have ice spices phone number
no because there's been a
misunderstanding I just need to clear up
what she think you know like in the
media yes
what'd you say bye it's it's ridiculous
my friend Nick this guy over here he
didn't know who she was he doesn't know
anything about anything he hasn't
listened to a song since why they didn't
know anything this guy Nick you got to
catch up it's fine we love him for who
he is and our other friend this British
guy who uh some guy he he dm'd her and
she she left them on red and then Nick
said who is that the Eskimo Spice Girl
Eskimo spice
you know Scary Spice Sporty Spice but
where they get Eskimo from she's from
the Bronx because ice oh okay so he
didn't know who she didn't know she was
from the Bronx I'm not mad at that that
wasn't you know you so you were gonna go
on the record and say that makes sense
as a bit I know her I mean I don't know
I know of her but I could see where he
put Eskimo with high spot Nick doesn't
know anything he's an idiot he's a
professional comedian you heard I don't
even know what the Spice Girls are he
doesn't even know the Spice Girls oh and
then he ain't he's not here so next time
you see Ricky's no longer with us
we got in big trouble because that right
and the guy that was on our podcast was
dating Taylor Swift they just broke they
just did this song they did a song
Because Of Us yeah of course that
feature we were the reasons
that's where I get our Dream Champs
[Music]
comedy podcasting stats from July Mark
Norman made the most guest appearances
last month going on a whopping 10 total
podcasts including this past weekend
Chrissy chaos taste buds are you garbage
Camp Gagnon the joke World comedy news
only fans bertcast Being Ian with Jordan
and on the gate the top three most
viewed episodes from last month starts
off with kill Tony's 10-year anniversary
show which has 1.8 million views since
being posted on July 3rd right behind
that was flagrant's episode featuring
Gideon at 1.6 million views followed by
Hulk Hogan on this past weekend with 1.5
be sure to subscribe to joke world right
now if you enjoyed this monthly wrap up
and want more content like this also any
subscribers who have not claimed their
free joke World stickers yet be sure to
check the link in the bio right now fill
out that form and we'll get those in the
mail as soon as possible thanks for
watching
at joke world
[Music]
and the world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out